all right tonight after accusing Saudi
Arabia's Crown Prince of murder and
calling his Nation a pariah Nation Biden
is once again on his knees obviously
begging for oil now the administration
is asking a court to Grant MBS the guy
that he says killed journalist Jamal
khashoggi immunity in a lawsuit
surrounding the the murder of khashoggi
we have a lot more coming up on that
we'll also bring in the very latest from
the all-important runoff race that is
going on in the great state of Georgia
Plus at least two disreputable
Democratic house lawmakers might soon be
stripped from their committee
assignments thanks to a precedent that
was set by their current boss Nancy
Pelosi we got a full report we'll also
hear the story from the first woman to
be elected governor of the great state
of Arkansas Sarah Huckabee Sanders will
join us in a minute how should Governors
now deal with CRT gender identity
classes now there are two schools across
the country that are allowing Satan
worshiping groups to meet on school
grounds okay what's happening and how do
you stop it but we begin tonight with
this with something inscribed on look at
that right there on the U.S Supreme
Court building Washington DC what does
it say Equal justice under the law those
five words are the very core of our
justice system without this Foundation
Nothing Else Matters as recently as of
recently millions of Americans and
frankly including me believe it's little
more than an inscription with one harsh
unyielding system if you are a
Republican or a conservative another
lighter more forgiving system if you are
a Democrat especially prominent
Democrats and have the last name Biden
or Clinton so tonight we're going to
focus on two key questions is equal
justice under the law dead in the United
States of America and if so can it be
brought back to life if not well our
constitution is worthless you might as
well just shred it because every law was
based on that document late last week
The Washington Post reported that the
FBI's unprecedented rate at Mar-A-Lago
revealed nothing nefarious instead of
ending the investigation Biden's doj by
the way he would have the power to stop
this appointed an aggressive left-wing
special prosecutor to dig more into all
of this and keep the probe into all
things Trump opened in perpetuity okay
the country has a lot of important
problems to deal with inflation high gas
prices open borders Etc and crime is
this equal justice now we're going to
get back to that special prosecutor in a
minute but first let's be clear this is
not normal for reference let's look at
three other high-profile cases that were
handled so much differently because
they're Democrats now it's a fact
Hillary Clinton she did mishandle a
mountain of classified evidence on her
unsecured private servers and that's
when she was with the state department
emails that were recovered 110 of them
contained classified information eight
email chains contained top secret
material another 36 contains secret
information another a-contained
confidential material and then of course
we have the 33 000 other emails that
well nobody ever found because they were
deleted with something nobody had ever
heard of called bleach bit they acid
washed the hard drive now these are the
emails that we know about the thirty
thousand and She's accused of attempting
to wipe the other servers all cleans and
then having people that work for smash
you know iPhones and blackberries and
other devices smash them into itsy bitsy
pieces and remove their SIM cards we do
know however that the server faced
hacking attempts from multiple countries
including China Serbia according to the
AP quote using a computer in Serbia the
hacker scan Clinton's basement server
and Chappaqua at least twice and get
this Clinton emails or even found on
Anthony Weiner's laptop during the FBI's
investigation into his sex crimes now
Hillary Clinton clearly put our
country's National Security at risk she
never faced an early morning raid from
the FBI she didn't get slapped with a
special prosecutor and after a few
months of Investigation well then FBI
director Jim Comey announced that no
reasonable prosecutor would ever
prosecute Hillary Clinton so I ask you
is that equal justice you decide
from the group of thirty thousand emails
returned to the state department in 2014
110 emails in 52 email chains have been
determined by the owning agency to
contain classified information at the
time they were sent or received
eight of those chains contained
information that was Top Secret at the
time they were sent 36 of those chains
contained secret information at the time
and eight contained confidential
information at the time although there
is evidence of potential violations of
the statutes regarding the handling of
classified information
our judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case which
brings us to Hillary Clinton's sturdy
dossier not only did Clinton mishandle
classified information but her campaign
was also doing something very sketchy in
Russia some might actually call this the
real collusion funneling money through a
law firm they paid an ex-formed spy
Christopher Steele to compile Russian
disinformation about Donald Trump
apparently the FBI didn't see that as a
problem instead they saw this as an
opportunity again we're asking a
question does America have equal justice
under the law despite warnings from a
doj official Bruce Orr and others that
the dossier was a political op research
document it was not to be trusted and
despite claims from the dossier author
himself Christopher Steele that the
material was unverifiable and despite
the dossier sub Source referring to the
claim as nothing more than bar talk the
FBI used the dossier to obtain a fisa
warrant and threes subsequent renewals
as a back door to spy on the Trump
campaign their transition team and of
course the White House as Andrew McCabe
said in an indicated no dossier they
wouldn't have gotten the fisa Warren
approved in fact the FBI was so
desperate for the salacious anti-trump
material by the way right in the lead up
to the 2016 election putting their
thumbs on the scale that they offered
Christopher Steele one million of your
dollars in early October 2016 if he
could corroborate anything in the
dossier but guess what he couldn't but
then after that at the end of October
they used the unverifiable dossier
anyway and straight up lied to fisa
court judges and affirmed that it was in
fact verified it was not verifiable the
consequences for all involved
non-existent but when it comes to Trump
or Republicans the upper echelon the
FBI's Washington field office search far
and wide for a crime that did not exist
they spent about 6 years doing it over
the course of a special prosecutor a
special counsel a search warrant of the
president's home numerous other warrants
for other Trump Associates when it comes
to Joe Biden and crimes that are in
plain sight the Washington field office
is nowhere to be found I'm asking does
this look like Equal justice to you
without any relevant experience here you
have at the time a guy coordinator
reports was addicted to crack cocaine at
a proclivity for women of the night
raking in millions and millions of
dollars from all over the world with no
experience three and a half million
dollar wire transfer from a Russian
oligarch known as the former first lady
of Moscow then a 100 million dollar
investment from this same oligarch into
a Biden length real estate firm a 1.5
billion dollar deal with the Bank of
China a five million dollar
interest-free forgivable loan what's an
interest-free forgivable loan another
100 grand for an international shopping
spree for Hunter and his family
compliments of a prominent Chinese
National and millions more from
Ukrainian oil and gas giant Barista
Holdings that's where Joe withhold the
billion of your dollars to get the
prosecutor fired because his son was
being paid Millions with no experience
and that's only the tip of the iceberg
Hunter likely had lucrative Financial
relationships with numerous Shady
foreign Nationals and more than a dozen
countries uh what was Hunter selling
what was his vast knowledge and
experience that warranted millions of
dollars being made was it just access to
his father did his father benefit
financially take a look
in 2019 shortly after announcing his
campaign for President Joe Biden told
the American people he had nothing to do
with and never had conversations with
his family about their business dealings
that was a lie the bidens flourished and
became millionaires by simply offering
access to the family
among the dozens of shale companies the
Biden set up there were millions of
dollars of wire transfers flights on Air
Force two to conduct personal business
and meetings with heads of state all
while Joe Biden was aware of what was
happening this is an investigation of
Joe Biden the president of the United
States and why he lied to the American
people about his knowledge and
participation in his family's
international business schemes
now we have a picture of Joe Biden with
Hunter and Hunter's foreign business
partners we have a number of them and in
messages found on Hunter's very real
laptop a cut of the proceeds was always
set aside for the big guy hunter
complained bitterly about having to give
up half of his income to quote pops
Biden claims he never talked about
business with his son it's an obvious
lie and even the White House Press
Secretary is having a hard time
explaining all of this illicit activity
take a look
the top Republican on the house
oversight committee Congressman Comer
has said that he's investigating the
president's involvement in his son
Hunter's foreign business dealings when
looking for your reaction to that and
and then on the merits of the
allegations can you address whether the
president was involved in any of his son
uh hunter or his brother's foreign
business deals so look I you know
um there's there's some a little bit of
uh interesting uh you know kind of
on-brand uh thinking here
huh on brand thinking no explanation no
special special counsel investigation no
special prosecutor Hunter's tax and
money laundering investigation has been
slow walk for years now and the media
mob is complaining that the House
Republicans might conduct actual
oversight do their job and investigate
possible public corruption in other
words again I ask is this equal justice
under the law is it possible we have a
president of the United States that is
financially compromised by China and
Russia and Ukraine and up to as many as
50 other countries the bidens did
business with far left radical David
Brock has been tasked with running
defense against anyone that dares
investigate Joe and Hunter that usually
means attacking and smearing and
slandering and at this point the bidens
appear to be above the law well if
you're a republican of any type well
it's now you know you face another
baseless investigation more special uh
prosecutors and of course with an
extreme bias according to a new report
from John Solomon Jack Smith helped the
IRS Target conservatives during the
lowest learner IRS scandal now this is
the same prosecutor that conducted a
hyper aggressive prosecution against the
former Virginia governor Bob McDonald
over quote bribery charges those charges
were tossed out by the U.S Supreme Court
but not before McDonald's life was
ruined so yes there is rampant political
bias at the doj the highest levels of
the FBI we don't have equal justice
under the law the at the federal level
and this is going to be what Jim Jordan
will be investigating and then you have
Congressman Comer on the other side will
be investigating Hunter and Joe and by
the way you should be worried that equal
justice might be dead forever and if
that's true this country is you might as
well say we're not a constitutional
republic anymore hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else